but whether it makes us human or not we
are the only animal that from an early
age six in my case in dollis Hill is
aware of the inevitability of
[Music]
death it's really great to see so many
of you here my name is chinny McDonald I
am director of Theos which is a religion
and Society think tank we uh explore the
role of religion in public life um and
we are really interested in Theology and
religion being relevant to kind of real
life and average people which is why
we're really delighted to have David Bal
with us tell us about the journey
towards the book um well uh so when I
wrote D's don't count uh there was a
section in that that was quite important
in terms of understanding my point about
anti-Semitism because I wanted to make
the point that anti-Semitism was racism
and it turned out that the easiest way
way of making people understand that
that anti-Semitism is racism and not
what a lot of people think it is which
is religious intolerance is to point out
that I'm an atheist but the Gusto would
kill me immediately uh in fact that my
great uncle Aro who was also an atheist
died in the wars or ghetto so it's a
central point about anti-Semitism uh
which is that the racists are not
interested in whether or not you're
religious it's the same now with white
supremacists chanting the Jews will not
replace Us in Charlotte fille they would
not ask me if I kept kosher before
setting light to my house so that was a
central point but then I realized that
people some people not Jews actually
were confused by the idea of what an
atheist Jew was and I sometimes would
explain it comically by saying I don't
believe in God I believe in Larry David
but then I thought I should say more
than that although actually it is a
thing like it turns out that like 50% of
Jews actually sort of identify as Jewish
but also atheists which is unusual for a
minority group associated with religion
and I once found out just how much this
is true like uh around here there's a
there used to be a synagogue in Hamstead
I'm not sure there is anymore but my I
guess my Rabbi I don't have a rabbi cuz
I'm an atheist but my Rabbi phoned me up
got my number cuz you know we're in
control of the world and uh he I don't
know I don't know how he got my number
he phoned me up and he and he said will
you be the person the sort of local Naf
celebrity who comes to like the manora
the can labra the Jews Like A Hanukah
outside the synagogue and I I didn't
really want to do that so I played what
I thought was my trump card I said I'm
sorry I'm really sorry to tell you this
Rabbi but I'm an atheist and he said so
am I and I thought hell it's
really it's really more widespread than
I realize
and and so from that from the notion of
what is an atheist Jew I thought well I
should try and write a book maybe that
tries to explain my particular type of
atheism uh and so that was the god
desire so disclaimer I'm a Christian and
I believe in God so I'm interested in
the conversation between between you
know the two of us I I loved your book
and I found it really moving at times
because it speaks to something that is
at the heart of humanity which is this
kind of wrestling with our mortality and
our infinitude um I have brought my
whole family here so my husband and my
two kids my 5-year-old um nearly six is
kind of obsessed with death at the
moment and keeps on coming up with
questions I think because the queen died
when he was you know starting school
he's seems to be kind of much more aware
of it so he asked me questions like well
if people die why doesn't God just make
a new one or do children die or all
these kind of questions yeah tell us
about why death um in the book why is
that the kind of kind of hurt well I
start the book it's very that's
interesting that you say you're
5-year-old is asking asking you those
questions because the book begins uh
with me at 6 years old praying to Hashem
who is the Hebrew God because I went to
a Jewish Primary School uh that I don't
want to well I want my life to go on in
some way after death and I'm praying I
remember for my parents to still be
around for my best friend Saul Jacob
Rosenberg it was that Jewish of school
uh to still be around uh and for my cat
FFA uh to still be around she was that's
quite Jewish as well uh anyway uh then I
I remember saying to my mom that I was
really terrified of this thing this new
thing that I'd found out about called
death and she said don't worry uh death
is just like a long sleep from which you
never wake up and since then I've been a
lifelong Insomniac
and I have so that's I actually do think
my insomnia could be traced to that and
and I think that's really fascinating
that you your children cuz I can't
remember with my own children now
they're 18 and 22 having that moment
where they first understood what death
was but I think it's very formative I
mean I think I do in the book suggest
that the thing that really separates us
from animals and we have a lot of
different ideas about what separates us
from the animals I think far too many
because I think at heart we are animals
but one of the things is we have an
awareness of death and the awareness of
death I think is what leads to the
creation of stories that outsmart death
right so the the the god desire I and I
could read a bit shall I read a bit and
that will perhaps give you a sense of
what I mean by the god desire so I use
um a couple of um quotes at the start of
this book uh and the quotes are before
the Divine Kingdom can be established in
events it has to be established in the
mind in the human imagination Bishop
Richard Harris thought for the day 4th
of November 2022 and we cherish the
illusion that exalts us more than a host
of baser truths Alexander a pushkit but
then by page five I'm already saying I
didn't really want to use those quotes
the one I wanted to use was this a close
friend once said to me but don't you
want to believe in God I said yes
desperately that's why I know he doesn't
exist it's the opening sentence of the
belief system a book by an atheist
thinker Virginia Brook but Virginia
Brook is a character of my own devising
who appears in my own play God's Dice
and using one of my own quotes as an
epigraph is just too Naf I thought I
might get away with it on the basis of
this book is about the non-existence of
something so perhaps it would be apt to
begin with a quote from a book that
doesn't exist I thought that might be
meta and clever enough to carry it
through but in the end it's just to Alan
Partridge a
move nonetheless the quote does sit at
the center of this essay most Arguments
for atheism are philosophical sometimes
they tie themselves in knots grappling
with the issue of how you can can prove
the non-existence of something at heart
they are based on the idea that there is
no evidence for God's existence
therefore he doesn't exist which might
seem like atheist job done but it isn't
as there is no concrete evidence for the
existance of for example Dark Matter
dark matter which makes up 94% of the
bloody Universe no evidence for it at
all it's just a conceit invented by
scientists to explain away the large
parts of existence that they can't
account for which is problematic from a
no God point of view as that's basically
the same conceit that priests and imams
and rabbis have always used God for my
argument is on the other hand in a
general sense psychological it requires
an admission which frankly most atheists
I've noticed aren't prepared to make
which is I love God the idea that is of
him for the purposes of this pmic I'm
going to stick with the patriarchal
traditional pronoun although I believe a
modern God would almost definitely have
a Twitter bio that ended they stroke
them who would not love a superhero dad
who chases off death some non-believers
reading this will think speak for
yourself it's common amongst atheists in
trashing religion also to trash the
rewards of religion or to be more
specific to disavow the presence in
themselves of what religion is there to
serve there is something a little Macho
in atheism some atheists Divine
correctly that what religion provides
for human beings is comfort and then in
a way that can feel a bit adolescent
they feel impelled to say essentially
Comfort that's for babies but humans a
subset of which includes all atheists
are babies however old and intellectual
and cynical they grow no matter how
adult and controlled we seem on the
surface underneath we are a hive of
wailing impulsive immediate need I'm
happy to admit to my own babyishness
this maybe because or rather why I am a
comedian much comedy is just that
stripping away the facade of adulthood
we are all winging adulthood truly
there's only one adult in the world
whose age in his soul lines up with the
age he in fact is and his name is
Michael
Gove I am flawed and shallow and scared
and often desperately in need of comfort
both psychological and physical I'm also
someone however with enough
self-awareness to perceive these as
urges rather than as ideas my thinking
self in other words is distinct from my
urgent one not all the time I often find
myself thinking I must eat now or I will
die even when it's only 11 in the
morning but I'm conscious even as I
think that that this isn't a logical way
to understand the world world or even
the phenomenon of feeling peckish I know
even as I experience desire that it is
desire and that desire provides no frame
for reality the god desire should not
have to lead to The God Delusion yet the
desire is real for me it is the very
intensity of it which alerts me to the
fact of fantasy the need to imagine that
there is an exit door somewhere through
which to escape constantly oncoming
death is one that I can conf L predict
exists within the Deep recesses of most
humans and the pressure of that desire
has always and will always lead to
Divine projection people talk a lot
about what it means to be human about
what separates us from the animals some
of that is lyrical love and empathy and
stuff I personally think it could be
pinned down to the fact that we are the
only animals who feel shame in
defecating but whether it makes us human
or not we are the only animal that from
an early age six in my case in dollis
Hill is aware of the inevitability of
death so it is impossible to look at the
repetitive creation of Legends across
every culture and throughout history
which in one way or another outsmart
death and promise immortality without
concluding that God is a projection of a
very fundamental desire within within us
for it not to be so
inevitable thanks um thank
you
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas